[Applause]
it's wonderful to be here with you on
this incredible night
a great sea buckingham palace turned
into a giant imac screen
as i watch those extraordinary images
it does make me think of all the
monumental and pioneering work of so
many visionary environmentalists that
have gone before
i'm so proud that my grandfather and my
father have been a part of those efforts
[Music]
and i'm in awe of people like the great
sir david attenborough
who look at the beauty and power of our
earth
and then work to celebrate and preserve
it
i think of rachel carson from america
wangari mathai from kenya
sunita naran from india
and so many others
while no one's grandmother thanks them
for talking about their age
my own grandmother has been alive for
nearly a century
in that time
mankind has benefited from unimaginable
technological developments and
scientific breakthroughs
and although those breakthroughs have
increased our awareness of the impacts
humans have on our world
our planet has become more fragile
[Music]
today in 2022
as the queen celebrates her platinum
jubilee the pressing need to protect and
restore our planet has never been more
urgent
[Music]
but like her
i am an optimist
decades of making the case for taking
better care of our world
has meant that environmental issues are
now at the top of the global agenda
more and more businesses and politicians
are answering the call
and perhaps most inspiringly the cause
is now being spearheaded by an amazing
and united generation of young people
across the world
congratulations to all of them
they won't accept the status quo
they won't accept that change is too
difficult to deliver
never before have we had so much power
to change the big things
in the past 70 years
mankind has put man on the moon
we have built the world wide web
and we have developed vaccines and
solutions to some of the most
life-threatening diseases on earth
when humankind focuses its minds
anything is possible
it's my firm hope
that my grandmother's words
are as true in 70 years time as they are
tonight
that as nations we come together in
common cause
because then there is always room for
hope
tonight has been full of such optimism
and joy
and there is hope
together if we harness the very best of
humankind
and restore our planet
we will protect it for our children
for our grandchildren and for future
generations to come
they will be able to say
with pride and what's been achieved
what a wonderful world
[Applause]